my talk of the table i have a big
question not for tony or gayle but for
you at home do you ever think about
changing your job without knowing where
it may lead this morning our lead
national correspondent david bagnum i
know that's funny i say yes at gilson
he introduces us to a popular news
anchor in new orleans karen swenson
who's doing just that after a very long
and successful career she's walking away
from her job at the cbs affiliate wwl
saying she is trusting the
when
universe
tv paid its final tribute
to its beloved lead anchor woman she
made the newsroom a more fun place and a
nicer place every single day karen
swenson paid tribute to the long list of
people whose stories she told i will
never forget you the lytel family the
mother and both of her children who beat
devastating brain tumors the slack
family from the lower ninth ward we lost
everything but what really mattered in
katrina you taught me about faith
and family and resilience but missing in
that narrative was her own list of
hardships so let's go back to 2005. oh
my god 2005.
right before we got married my husband
and i got married
they found a benign
tumor
so six weeks before my wedding to the
day i had massive surgery
and they told me during that surgery you
may never have children but medical
advances helped to change that when she
gave birth to a daughter
that same year hurricane katrina wiped
out new orleans and while she reported
from the only local tv station able to
stay on the air her own home was
destroyed and i went down this rabbit
hole for really years
just
missing the house that we had lost the
friends we had lost the way of life that
we had lost she ended up leaving new
orleans for a dream job anchoring a
morning show in her native boston but
she and her family longed to be back in
the big easy and in 2011 we moved back
to new orleans and my husband
six months later was diagnosed with
advanced cancer i thought oh my god
what is happening
my daughter was only nine
john the new orleans police detective
and love of her life
died six years later i've been through a
lot of life's changes and if i can help
somebody else navigate it a little bit
easier
then there's a purpose for all of it
that's a saying in new orleans ain't
dare no more
that purpose has helped to push her to
walk away from a successful career on
television and run a company called
life's about change it's her company her
idea
to sell products that are made by people
who've changed their lives
methamphetamine i started at the age of
15.
went to prison at the age of 20. i
had my first child at 16 and i didn't
know how to navigate that and so
i started using opiates at 18. jenna and
amanda are now successful potters who
imprint karen's line of coffee mugs with
words to live by we have faith kindness
peace we're living testimonies of what a
life can look like changed so the idea
with the candles is what
so the idea from the candles came from a
doctor who was helping my husband and i
to navigate his cancer journey
and the day he was diagnosed she said i
want you to go get a candle and then i
want you to watch the wax disappear and
the wax in your cancer cells you said
visualize it what's your intention for
folks who buy the candle from you i hope
that they see the flame and they think
about their own inner strength life's
about change started as a t-shirt
company this might be my favorite time
for change
single again
good afternoon i'm karen swenson for
several years now karen swenson has
juggled that job at wwl tv
with finding special vendors the candles
that we have those are created by an
american veteran joins the military at
33 because she's decided it's time to
give back
and that seems to me to be the
underlining of the company that's it
it's the focus on the present and the
gratitude and the joy that comes with it
always
look for the positive or at least try
to be in a state of joy it will help you
navigate it so when my husband was sick
we looked for the person who beat it
when he passed i looked for the widow
who was still smiling
karen's website is filled with stories
like that but there is one story not
there the one that hit hard after her
appendicitis
so as i'm
recuperating and i pull up the pathology
reports
and fully expecting to be fine and it
said carcinoma
and i was like
no way
and all of a sudden they said uh
had you not had this other pain your
appendix that kind of cancer is so
insidious
that by the time you usually find it's
over i don't like even speaking about it
because to me it gives it it gives it
strength you some power and that's why i
never talked about it before honestly
but did that period help drive you to
give the final word to your boss that
i'm hanging it up
this twist of fate that has saved my
life right right so yes and you start
thinking maybe it's time to
untether yourself from the desk and just
sort of blindly go out there and just
trust the universe so it is not goodbye
i am not leaving new orleans i'm just
pivoting life is about change and it's
time i live up to the mantra so here we
go a new adventure after one heck of a
ride so
thank you new orleans here's to you
cheers
[Applause]
david once again i'm telling you you
find the most amazing people i'm
thinking about karen swenson massive
tumor
her home's destroyed her husband dies of
cancer she has appendicitis and yet she
still has figured out a way to find the
positive i'm in awe of this woman
she's the brightest light on television
gail i never met the woman before this
but when i heard she was retiring and
walking away why would karen swenson
leave television you were the queen in
new orleans and she's doing it because
there's got to be a bigger purpose a
better purpose a more fulfilling purpose
that also gives back everything by the
way that's involved in our company is
american made and join me in wishing her
a happy birthday today happy birthday
happy birthday karen happy happy
birthday
hey hey david i like what she says about
the candles i'd actually like to get a
couple of those when you just watch it
burn down when what it represents boy
she's she's something else how about
she's special we're gonna watch her
karen thank you for all the good years
on the cbs affiliate new orleans wwl tv
that's right they say go ahead tony well
i was gonna say david you know people
are afraid of change but change can be
magical what about you going into this
story were you someone afraid of change
did it change your perspective
oh
that's a good question i don't know tony
that i would have the guts to walk away
from this career but then again i love
what i do and if they didn't pay me to
do it i'd still do it now don't get me
wrong karen loved her job but think
about this single mom 52 years old
stepping away relying on her 401k to do
this she's betting on herself and i end
with this if you bet on yourself you'll
never let yourself down
that's right david that is true i was
once told i was once told what you go
through can help you get through karen
swenson here's to you david thank you so
much happy birthday amen